ايه بعض من القرارات
الاخيره هل اثمر اي تواصل مع الحكومه
تواصل
مع مسار تحدي كما وصفته الذي يعانيه
المستشفى
[موسيقى]
مستشفى 57 هي طبعا وزاره التضامن
الاجتماعي وتاخذ على الاشراف من وزاره
الصحه وكذا وكذا جهه وزاره في البلد همم
احنا طول الوقت من يوم ما فتحت المستشفى
لحد النهارده في دعم وتسهيلات من كل
الجهات الرسميه المستشفى قائمه على
التبرعات وهمم ما فيش اي احد في الشعب
المصري ما تبرعش همم فزي ما باقول همم
المستشفى همم بتلقى الدعم من كل الجهات
الرسميه همم وتسهيلات من كل الجهات
الرسميه همم وهي قائمه على التبرعات وكل
الشعب المصري بيعتبر على المستشفى همم ومن
اول يوم من الكلام ده من كل يتبرع دكتور
يعني لماذا طلبيات من الادويه والمعدات
الطبيه الضروريه لم تصل للمستشفى بعد
هي دي مش حاجه الخاصه بالمستشفى بس يعني
المستشفى
كجزء من مش حتى في مصر بس العالم كله
دلوقتي من ساعه الكورونا خصوصا والمشاكل
التي تحصل في الاستيراد والتصدير في مشاكل
في الافيلا بليتي بتاعه الادويه في كل
المستشفيات العالم همم
مريض السرطان احتياجاته كبيره جدا من
الادويه احتجاجات كبيره جدا من المستلزمات
والتقنيات المتقدمه همم هي هو التحدي
الحقيقي في ان احنا محتاجين بالاعداد اللي
عندنا ان احنا نستمر في الحفاظ على نفس
المستوى جوده الخدمه المقدم ومع زياده
اعداد ومع تاثر
الحاله الاقتصاديه للعالم عموما والدوله
للمستشفى بالتبعيه همم كل احتياج للتبرع
زاد فهو التبرعات موجوده التبرعات همم ك
كميات ما قلتش لكن همم احتياجنا انت
تبرعات اكثر في الفتره دي همم مطلوب علشان
همم
القدره الشرعيه بتاعه المستشفى قلت عن قبل
كده همم
ما بتقدر توفره قبل كده بموردها وبالاضافه
لده زياده اعداد المرضى المتوفيين اتحدث
عن ايام كم هي المده الزمنيه التي
تكفي لهذه الاموال الحاليه اليوم وما بعد
هذه
ما هو مصير المستشفى
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله عمره ما هتقفل يعني المستشفى
طول ما الدعم موجود طول ما الناس الجدعان
موجوده وبتتبرع على المستشفى ان شاء الله
عمرها ما هتقفل والتحدي الحقيقي بتاعنا
دلوقتي هو ان احنا محتاجين تبرعات علشان
نستمر في الحفاظ على نفس المستوى الخدمه
احنا المستشفى اخذت شويه قرارات لتقليل
المالي ده همم منها مثلا همم الطاقه
الاستيعبيه بتاعه المستشفى قالت لان
الطاقه الاستعابيه مش بس عدد اسره الطاقه
الاستعابيه يعني توافر ادويه الطاقه
الاستعابيه يعني همم وجود همم كوادر بشريه
واعتاق طبيع على اعلى كفاء يقدم خدمه همم
كل ده تاثر في الفتره الماضيه والطقه
الاستعلاميه بالتالي تاثرت فالمستشفى
ابتدت تقلل شويه في ال- ال- ال- ال-
الطاقه الاستعلام او يعني في في في اعداد
المرضى التي يتم قولها همم كان في برده
همم تم مراجعه الطريقه التي يتم تقديم بها
الخدمه للمرضى همم فالمستشفى مثلا كان قبل
كده بتقوم بمتابعه المرضى بعد الشفاء من
السرطان وكل العلاج مدى الحياه احنا حددنا
دلوقت فتره المتابعه لخمس سنين بعد انتهاء
برود كل العلاج